funny enough I I have my first date in a
long time I'm excited for your your
night tonight I'm not
um I dread these things because they're
yeah they're awkward what are you doing
what what yeah what's the date well
first of all the gentleman offered to
pick me up which I was so bold over by I
was like sure that's a gentlemanly thing
to do and then we were going to go all
the way downtown to this long dinner
everyone says when you go on a date with
someone don't do the dinner do a drink
but I don't know better I like the
dinner you know then you know if it
doesn't work you get to actually talk
and yeah it's you're going to have a
great time got a good feeling about what
really yeah I got a good what if you get
weird Vibes right out of the gate though
then what then run yeah then you go to
the bathroom and you call a friend and
and you have them give you a surprise
call do that you want me to do that yes
will you please I'll be your friends
really yeah yeah